good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy monday it is
time
to rise and grind it is time to rise and
grind but it's never been harder to rise
and grind
it never has been harder this is such a
monday monday the monday-est monday of
all of the mondays
yesterday was such a sunday so many
scaries as you guys know
we took a girls trip a bachelorette
party with no bachelorette
on wednesday of last week we went to
nashville and we had
the best time we really just like did
the most in every kind of
aspect and now we are paying the price
we are paying
the price it is a high price to pay
honestly it's expensive
it's expensive but it was so so much fun
and the fact that we came back like on
saturday afternoon was just
revolutionary right we have like we had
like 24 hours to decompress before we
could you know get back to the rising
and grinding yeah so like
normalize going on a weekend trip from
wednesday to saturday i agree there's
like actually a lot of value in that
because first of all
your like main days on the trip are like
wednesday thursday friday and it's like
not that busy
like i saw what brought downtown
broadway and nashville looked like on
saturday night we had already left and
it was
actual pandemonium like it looked like
an apocalypse i never saw somebody it
was
times square on new year's eve and for
us when we went thursday and friday
night it was busy but it was not even
close to that yeah so that's pretty
sweet like if you can get the work days
off which everybody like
took their pto in advance and it was
kind of a life hack to like just go in
the middle of the week come back and
have your weekend in front of you
yeah and honestly it was such a like
vibrant weekend in nashville i don't
know if like everyone got the memo but
we ran into like so many people we knew
it was just like
it was a vibrant weekend and then when
we were out on the lake
on thursday we got the notification
about the cdc
saying that if you're vaccinated you no
longer need to wear a mask
period unless you're in a nursing home
uh
subway train or public transportation
but
period on saturday night live it was
honestly one of the worst episodes i'd
ever seen
but colin jose was like you know people
were celebrating as the cbc announced
that you don't have to
vaccinated people don't have to wear
masks
inside except if you go anywhere because
like the list is like
subway plane train restaurant like no
it's not it's
public transportation that includes
subway plane train it's nursing homes
and it's hospitals
the list they had on snl was a little
bit longer that's what i read
whatever um it's a joyous occasion and
just really feels like i don't know
like it's all really happening it's all
really happening it was a great place to
be to celebrate
i just was such an amazing weekend like
i feel like my [ __ ]
my love for country music had been like
blowing lulling you know there just
wasn't that much to
judge it up and after this weekend like
yeah it's over the respect is over for
the other genres
completely agree the respect i have for
country music is through the roof
astronomical
and the respect i have for just like
different cities you always forget like
well not recently but overall like
people from new york
tend to like have this attitude that
like new york is the best place ever um
but you really realize how like
it's really not and there's so many
fabulous other cities out there with
like so much more to offer like
nashville in terms of activities like we
were overwhelmed with choices you know
during the day during the night there
was just
so many choices so many choices and it's
really a town like encourages drinking i
don't know like how or why but like
with the laws like you could just like
drink like everywhere and anywhere
yeah we did so many activities that were
just so
like good clean fun like that bus
driving through
nashville like where you just like say
it's called the honky tonk expressway
there's a few different companies we did
that one literally
like the most fun ever yeah and
just like so much serotonin fresh air
good music good vibes like it was
you don't get that but what was funny
every day because we chose to go
wednesday to saturday
when we were on that bus it was a friday
at noon like people were working and we
were driving through these like
corporate areas like
blasting life is a highway with like our
tits out and it was like people were
literally on their lunch break
yeah no which is crazy like the you
people just like stare at these buses
but
that's the dichotomy of nashville it's
like they're girls on their lunch break
and then there are girls on their
bachelorettes
yeah yeah but also like yes technically
a bachelorette with no bachelorette is a
girl's trip
but we did all of the standard
bachelorette activities so like that's
what
differentiates it from a girls trip yeah
um like everybody everywhere we went
just assumed we were a bachelor party
but we
really weren't no and when you saw i
planned the itinerary so when you sign
up for like these events like topgolf or
this honky tonk expressway they ask what
type of event you're having and there's
no
girls trip so i selected bachelorette
for most of them because
that was the vibe we were going for and
when we showed up at topgolf and i
checked in they were like are you here
for claudia's bachelorette
i guess i am hello it was just an
amazing trip
normalized taking girls trips like they
were so fun and it was nice to like
first of all
it was kind of like a chosen news
network retreat because we had the red
heads we had mood with lauren elizabeth
we had the snatcher
um but we haven't seen lauren
elizabeth in like a year over a year so
it was so nice to see her and lauren
brought her friends some of whom we knew
some of whom we didn't know yet so it
was just like
nice to be with new energy because i
feel like i see the same five people
every day
yes and they're literally all in this
room so it was just
like get your gal pals together bring
you know camp friends school friends
college friends home friends and just
like
mix it up and live like this is the time
to live you know norma would have been
so proud
i don't know if she was telling her
instagram stories but she would have
been proud because we had an airbnb and
like we did not spend any time there
like we really made the most of every
second once our boots were on the ground
in nashville like
bus club another club bus no
sleep that was us that was us it was
really
it was superb such a great boost of
serotonin
and i'm just so glad that we did it me
too and like honestly before the trip i
was just kind of dreading it because
like i had just been away
and i wanted to kind of be home and i
was just like it's just gonna be a lot
and once i got there like there's
something about the energy in nashville
like when i step foot out of the uber
onto broadway for the first time like
you know when people like leah michelle
went to broadway for the first time
broadway new york it's like
i'm gonna be a star i like hopped out of
the uber on broadway in downtown
nashville and i was like
i'm gonna be drunk like i it was just
it's such a special place if you've
never been to downtown oh
it is just sickening it's such a special
place i was also like feeling
like just scared nervous for the trip
because you [ __ ] are crazy
yeah we are crazy um and it's not really
like a grandma friendly environment no
it's not
but you know you kept up i kept up and i
took things at my own pace
and that's all you can ask for and i
feel like when we were younger like if
somebody was not feeling well or like
somebody was hungover and they wanted to
go home before we went out like
everyone would be like no and like
people would follow them home
and it just like kind of ruins it by the
trip where it's like you went to dinner
and you were like i can't
hit downtown and we were like okay and
you just like went by yourself
and we chugged along like you have to
the thing with the girls trip is like
we're here for a greater cause you know
and who we lose along the way is just
no collateral and for the girls it's
actually so important to listen to your
body
because if you start ignoring like what
your body is telling you like
for me at dinner it was i started
feeling like i was still on the boat
and it was the motion of the ocean or
lake um penny pine whatever it's called
and i was like it was like petty people
[Laughter]
and i kept going like i would have
suffered the next day and the next day
was
the best day of my life like from the
moment i woke up till we went to sleep
didn't even nap like we did the bus and
then we went to such a fabulous lunch
and then we went to topgolf and honky
talking and like i'm so glad that i
listened to my body the night before
because i was able to experience all
that to the fullest
now i know everyone knows this because
it's like a really popular franchise but
my god topgolf is fun
like 100 i didn't realize i thought it
was just like a range where you just
like stand around and hit balls
but they haven't they they kind of
mimicked bowling where it's like
everyone is a player and there's like
different points
and for the first you get two hour
windows and for the first hour i thought
like people were just hitting balls i'm
like my god this is boring
and i was just drinking then i realized
there's this whole interface
and you like play like like you do
bowling and it's so
fun and i had the best time yeah i'm
glad that we did the actual competition
mostly because i won
you just want to let everyone know um i
was the winner of
our topgolf and i feel like i didn't
really tell like broadcast that
or anything so i don't want to like take
the time today to say that i won
no i i think that it's it's kind of good
that you didn't broadcast because there
was kind of like a technicality on my
oh my god on my player ship like
somebody took two of my hits sam frankel
so it was just like it was already
uneven so like you didn't actually win
you know no no but even if you had
gotten like a hole in one on both two
hits i still would have won that's how
much
further ahead i no actually if i had
gotten a holy one on both two i'd say
literally would have won by a hundred
points
those are each like 25 points she's
lying no no i'm 100 serious whatever
they need to top golf in new york that
is a message because like i would do
that
every weekend yeah that is the message
it was there's one in new jersey
but i'm not going to new jersey uh maybe
but
but yeah they could use one in new york
but it's just so much real estate yeah
but there is like a huge
um chelsea piers golf range but that's
like serious and not like drinking
and no but i'm saying there's space for
it because they did it in chelsea yeah
and also like everything is out of
business so maybe it's time for top golf
to save our nation to save to save the
city yes
hashtag save the city hashtag save the
city bring in topgolf all in all we had
the most amazing weekend we met
so many toasters and that's why i think
i just have like a special place in my
heart for nashville because it's so
toasty i saw like
people wearing merch so many toasters
and it was just fabulous and i just
really like i'm so upset that i'm here
now
you know yeah yeah no no no offense to
you no but
i'm grateful to what we had and i need
to acknowledge the space that we are in
and it's like now we have those memories
like we didn't have a fresh batch of
memories for 18 months
that's true yeah we have these ones we
have these pictures like i'm just always
going through my photos we have these
inside jokes
inside jokes videos mark
that's an inside joke you guys um we
have all these like giggly little
moments
so like we're so yeah we're so
we're so lucky for that we really are so
so
so so lucky so yeah
that was our weekend um it was really
fantastic and now we're back ready to do
what we do with the new joi davine
that is necessary so necessary to
constantly be finding new joadaves and i
think we've done that
i think we've done that too also the
rest of the weekend was pretty low-key
watch brewery yesterday which was like
yeah so sweet and cute bro was a bad boy
should we talk about it um
i don't think we need to like embarrass
him in trouble with him but he wasn't on
his best behavior i think he was
confused i think he's like feeling a
little lost right now as like a
person but i did love watching brew like
for the first two hours like
him and thea were just like going after
each other then they both were so pooped
from being
so cute that they just laid in my lap
and then i was thinking i'm like this is
what it's like if you ever have two dogs
and it was just like delightful brew is
such a sweet young man like a real he's
gonna grow up to be a wonderful
a wonderful man yeah no i agree he's
such a sweet soul and i'm so glad you
got to experience some of the joys of
brew
yeah but his bowels do they just need
work yeah they do need work i don't know
like
how he's such a hydrated king
considering like i don't even give him
enough water for how much he pees no he
literally peed all over my house
but that is neither here nor there
because without further
due to brew here are the past five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
and today's episode is very
appropriately brought to you by relief
band because if we had had
our relief band in nashville when we
were on the boat i think it really would
have helped you you would have been
relieved
yes because did you know that one out of
three americans regularly suffers from
nausea
we've all experienced that horrible
feeling whether it's in the backseat of
a car staring at your phone
after one too many on a night out with
friends or even just the anxiety of a
work day
nausea can ruin a day force us to change
our plans and in the most severe cases
make us unable to function for those who
can relate we've got good news because
you've got to check out relief band
the number one fda cleared anti-nausea
wristband that has clinically been
proven to quickly relieve and
effectively prevent nausea and vomiting
associated with motion sickness anxiety
migraines hangovers morning sickness
chemotherapy and so much more the
product is 100 drug-free
non-drowsy and it provides all-natural
relief with zero side effects for as
long as needed
the technology was originally developed
over 20 years ago in hospitals to
relieve nausea from patients
but now through relief band it is
available to the masses i was literally
thinking how
silly it was for us not to bring yeah
our relief bands to nashville because we
had all of it we had hangovers
motion sickness car rides like we were
just hitting all of the nausea spots and
we really needed that we played
ourselves
how it works is that the relief band
will stimulate a nerve in the wrist that
travels to the part of the brain that
controls nausea
then it blocks the signal your brain is
sending to your stomach telling you that
you're sick
relief ben is the only over-the-counter
wearable device that has been used in
hospitals and oncology clinics
to treat nausea and vomiting so if you
know someone who deals with nausea
relief ban makes a great gift
as the world reopens back up don't let
the fear of nausea keep you on the
sidelines
right now relief ban has an exclusive
offer for morning toast listeners if you
go to reliefband.com and use the promo
code toast
you'll receive 20 off plus free shipping
and a no questions
asked 30-day money-back guarantee so
head to r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d
dot com and use the promo code toast for
20 off plus free shipping
sign on relieve yourself please
just like brew did all over my couch
stop
brew i love you no i didn't mind first
story
john mulaney and olivia munn are dating
according to multiple reports
the news comes days after it had been
confirmed that melania and his wife anna
marie tendler had split after six years
of marriage
she had said i am heartbroken that john
has decided to end our marriage in a
statement to page six
i wish him support and success as he
continues his recovery
so i don't even think we were because we
were away last week we didn't even cover
the fact that john mullaney
is getting divorced yes and it's two
people who literally like
haven't i think i speak for both of us
when it's like we have absolutely no
stand-up
towards sean malini not in a batter in a
positive way he's just not my personal
type of comedian but i know that there
are people who are
so die-hard obsessed with him and
especially his marriage we're john
delaney neutral
we are completely neutral like i could
not care less but
i know that there are so many marriage
stands out there and they're like really
devastated about this
because from her statement it's like
clear like she did not want this
right and now days later it coming out
that he's dating olivia munn it feels as
though he left her for olivia munn
yeah and this feels like a little it
just feels dirty to me like i i feel
like
i john mullaney first of all being seen
with like another celebrity is just like
kind of crazy to me like
he's just been married to like a
commoner if you will for so long and i
just didn't see this for him
especially olivia munn who's
i don't want to say anything mean
because i actually really like her i'm
just like i'm i'm shook
by this like i just feel like she's been
in the news a lot recently
yeah well now i'm trying to look at
things like from the uh from olivia
munn's pov and it's like she was eating
aaron rodgers for so long and they never
were engaged or anything like that and
now he's like
has ships being built around the world
for him with shaylene so i feel like she
needed to like
do something for herself yeah well
wasn't she recently linked to chris
pratt as well or something no not chris
pratt sorry no but you're saying someone
see someone she she's just been like
dating around
casey musgrave's husband yes thank you
thank you thank you
so there's just like so i'm like i
thought she was still there you know
yeah
but now she's here no now she's here and
i'm just kind of trying to acknowledge
the space that she's currently in
because i just never saw these two
people like in my life
like being compatible but i never i also
really never saw
him yeah that's true so um
everyone's like really shocked by this i
would say the timing is pretty shocking
it just like kind of
points towards something untoward right
which is shocking as well
because john mulaney recently left rehab
yes so i figured he would be in a great
headspace and like
channel that towards his marriage but
he's not doing that yeah maybe he's
channeling towards himself and just you
know doing what's best for him
yeah it feels like a lot of things are
in flux for john malini yeah
also i just like when he did go to rehab
olivia munn tweeted sending so much love
and support to john mullaney you got it
what was that a joke no there it is on
december 21st 2020 sending so much love
and support to john delaney
you got this heart emoji lightning bolt
emoji that's kind of weird
do you think that they knew each other
then or or maybe she just like speaks
out on
celeb happenings well that begs another
question
this is going to be really mean what
does olivia munn do like
i feel like she's an actress i haven't
seen her act in anything in like years
she's she's just always in the news yeah
no and i know she's a part owner of wag
the dog walking app yeah because you're
always like is that olivia munn in the
commercial
and it is because she's like a equity
owner okay this is what she's in because
she's an actress but i do feel like when
we were with everyone when the news came
out so many people were like
but in what is she an actress yeah like
okay she's an x-men i think she's in
like a lot of
the like the men ex and we don't watch
those movies
but there and then there are so many
other random movies um
but like i've seen her buddy games oh
the newsroom that's what i remembered
her from
i've seen her and stuff i i know i know
who she is oh this christmas party is
really what i know her from yes me too
i know that she's an actress i'm just
saying like it feels like lately
in like maybe the last three years the
only things
she's like written up for is who she's
dating
so it's like who what else does she do
yeah it's a good question but maybe
she's now an investor
in things like wags i mean wag is a
great platform except for like the
couple dogs that we're missing but yeah
that's just collateral
yeah it is but no i hear what you're
saying i do feel like
but i do also feel like she's just in
stuff like x-men that we don't watch
that we don't watch
for sure well i hope that this is the
real deal you know
and i feel very like a an overwhelming
amount of sadness for petunia
is that her name ann taylor oh wait ann
marie
her name is petunia now oh they have a
dog named petunia everyone was like but
what about petunia i thought that was
the wife well i feel bad for petunia too
where parents are splitting up
yeah that's rough do they have kids yes
i feel like no
oh my god are you okay you didn't get my
joke i got it
i'm not sure it's rough for patonia and
ann taylor reed what's her name
and taylor joy yeah no that's um
beth beth yeah no her name is
anna justice for the mullany
crew you know hope everyone finds what
they're looking for and just as for the
people who like literally
have a poster of john and anna taylor
joy on their walls because that's like
their relationship goals
aspirational couple yeah yeah i feel
that that's always sad when like one of
those goes down
but we've been experiencing that all
year but again i can't stress enough
like how neutral i am and how much i
don't care about these people
yes i agree but the morning toast we
have listeners from all different places
with all different interests yeah so we
report the news for you
and some people well actually we're all
interested in miranda cosgrove
i think we're all interested
miranda cosgrove reveals icarly premier
date talks set photos and characters
10 years later miranda cosgrove received
the best birthday gift on friday the
news that
the icarly revival series will premiere
june 17th
on paramount plus the actresses icarly
castmates jerry traynor nathan kress
c mosley and jaden triplett were on set
to celebrate cosgrove turning 28 with a
cake and then they revealed their
announcement once again jeanette mccurdy
is not a part of it yeah so she did this
interview and kind of gave like a few
updates like here are the updates oh
okay carly has gone through a lot over
the
past 10 years i mean it's hard to be a
child webcam star
and then just kind of fade into a
relevancy yeah and also like the
internet has changed so much over the
last 10 years like how has icarly kept
up
oh that's a good question do you think
carly's going to be like an influencer
like she's gonna be
a podcast i think she's gotta be but so
with the freddy character he's gone
through a couple divorces
miranda revealed spencer has become very
wealthy so there's a lot of different
dynamics and different things going on
but he stayed in his same apartment i
read that somewhere as for carly she
went to college and is pretty successful
um but she's kind of in between where
freddie and spencer are at
spencer who's the most successful of all
the characters still resides in the
original lofty and carly lived in
though he's remodeled it a bit cosgrove
says that she and trainer worked with
the set designer to keep some of the
flair from the old series in the new set
i don't know why i'm like anti-remote
but here for this no i know like
maybe because like this particular show
just like
holds a special place in my heart but
like i'm not like angry about this i
don't know why i think
because i feel like with icarly it's
like for the last 10 years it's like
we've been referencing her like what is
she up to like the internet was just
getting started like there's so much
there to unpack
i think what you're trying to say is
that i carly was ahead of her time no
she was ahead of her time but like
with lizzie mcguire like lizzy was like
a basic [ __ ] like i'm not worried what
she's up to you know like she's
100 percent all taken care of had that
entrepreneurial spirit
trailblazer like i wouldn't be surprised
if carly has a podcast with tnn like
carly what's your channel please like
and so it's like
what is this teen who was a trailblazer
back then
right up to now honestly like she's the
next bill gates i want to know
no you're 100 right like and i really
feel like maybe
why we're so for this reboot is because
we kind of operate in this space and i
think we both really acknowledge that
we were so heavily influenced by carly
and her show
harley um and just like her
entrepreneurial spirit and her
joad aviv for her job so i think that
this is great and i think it was a great
message i think that's why
so many young kids who watched icarly
grew up to be influencers
because we were so influenced by icarly
being the original influencer if that
makes sense
yeah no i think she showed everyone that
like you can do what you love
yeah you can be on the internet you can
be yourself and that if you do what you
love you will never work a day in your
life
right and so everyone's out here trying
to do that i really do hope they update
like her job like
maybe okay she's pretty successful after
college but she's not feeling fulfilled
so she gets back into the web space
and launches a podcast and it becomes
huge yeah or like a youtube channel like
there's so much that carly could be up
to like
is she on tick tock i want to know where
carly sees the trends going
yeah she's a trend forecaster let's talk
about the genetic majority of it all
because they have
cast someone as a replacement for like
carly's best friend
but it's not like the same name it's
just that harley has a new best friend
carla is the new best friend
i think um and there's a lot of backlash
like people are very um
i mean when i think about this i feel as
though jeanette was
offered to be in it and she didn't want
to be in it i don't know
i feel like she doesn't want anything to
do with these things here's the question
is he who shall not be named involved in
this project
i don't know that's a good question i
don't think so well i think
i guess the show i am db yeah yeah i
wonder if he gets like royalties
he definitely does he might not be
actively working on set yeah
but he created the show so yeah and
janette
has been in in a few subtle ways kind of
outspoken about her experience
so i totally respect her decision not to
get involved
i don't know we'll have to do some
investigative work yeah because
that that's going to be a problem so
this like so many other things
is layered yeah we just got to get to
the bottom of it
we just got to peel back the layers like
an ogre
like an onion like a fat drink
oh man that was a funny episode last
week that was really funny are you ready
for our next story
is it the next story that's brought to
you by better help
yes it is please is there something
interfering with your happiness or
preventing you from achieving your goals
better help will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed thera
professional therapist
where you can start communicating in
under 48 hours better help is not a
crisis line and it is not self-help it
is professional counseling
and it's all done securely online the
service is available for clients
worldwide where you can log into your
account anytime
and send a message to your counselor
you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
or video phone sessions
so you never have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room as you do
with traditional therapy
better help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change counselors if
needed
it's more affordable than traditional
offline counseling and financial aid is
available
better help wants you to start living a
happier life today visit
betterhelp.comtoast
that's betterhelp.comtoast and join the
over 1 million people who have taken
charge of their mental health with the
help of an experienced professional
so many people have been using better
help that they are recruiting additional
counselors in all 50 states
so today's episode is sponsored by
better help and the morning toast
listeners will get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
toast
there's never a bad time to start taking
care of you
then have their slogan i just made that
up i mean it's that's powerful
it's powerful yeah like i'm impacted
yeah are you idiot he's
inspired yeah he always every day in
every way i didn't want to be on camera
today he said quote i wasn't feeling
myself you know what
sometimes self-care looks like not being
on camera hundred percent actually
that's
the case that would never be on camera
self-care looks like audio only
literally are you ready for our next
story
such a tough question you know it's
layered you know what because i'm like
i'm actually getting a little depressed
i can't get these stamps off my hand
from nashville can you
i got some of them off my wrist but
there's like remnants and i'm not even
mad i'm like avoiding washing my hands
because like
just reminds me of all the memories and
the giggles and the songs and the shots
you if you ever got a tattoo it should
be of like the legend
stamp on your hand
i have never in my life felt any sort of
urge to get a tattoo
but now that you just said that like i
love that idea
so it looks like i'm always like like a
couple i should find like my favorite
bars and restaurants like in the country
and then get like
the like i just went to all of them in
one night all on one hand i love
that idea ben is here he's like staring
me down
he said don't come home that's fine i'll
um she'll be going her favorite bars and
restaurants i'll stay at mark's place
and also
just a little nashville inside joke you
guys don't worry about it also that way
you can always get into your favorite
bars and restaurants
you're like i was already here life hack
oh my god i kind of like
really want to do it think about it i'm
just going to remove before i die so i
could be buried into your cemetery
yeah or maybe you could get like a a
temporary one like that you do every six
months
yeah i mean that sounds like a lot of
work i can barely get my nails done but
then you can stay true to your values
yeah and you have what you want no
there's something there there's
something there there's something there
but think about it like with all big
decisions just think about it yeah yeah
okay so now i feel like after letting us
know about how you're feeling about your
hand
it's time for the next story okay what's
it about which is that justin hartley
made his red carpet debut with
girlfriend sophia
pernas at the 2021 mtv movie and tv
awards okay so like
the article is saying girlfriend but
these two fully showed up with wedding
bands
he's wearing a wedding band she's
wearing a band not like a a diamond ring
or anything which makes it even more
like a wedding because it's like anyone
can put on a red carpet like uh oh like
a nice big cocktail ring for a while and
maybe
like the one that the jeweler had only
fit on her ring finger yeah
but they're literally saying hello we're
committed to each other we are married
to one another
can i tell you something like personal
sure i despise
justin hartley like with the intensity
of ten thousand sons
not even because of the whole crochet
thing which he was a dick for and like
uh it's part of it you ever just like
hate someone
yes i know [ __ ] rhyme or reason no i
do
have those feelings sometimes and i
don't feel that way about him ready
because justin hartley gives me
major justin timberlake energy i like
that's how i feel mediocre white man
no i feel like justin hartley like of
course i want to take out my distaste
for this is us like
yes oh that's a huge part of it also
breaking news that we didn't discuss
last week this is us
ending finally you guys we've been
delivered we've been delivered
no so of course like i already don't
like him because of this is us and then
you see christelle and like it's just
like
[ __ ] weird but then i watched little
and i thought he was
so handsome and okay jackie he was in
little for literally one second no and
and that's the sort of impact he made on
me and now i'm watching these two show
up on the red carpet
like literally looking so [ __ ] happy
and in love like in a genuine
way no genuine way no like seriously
their hand up like that on their man
like
unless they really [ __ ] love them you
know what i'm just kind of going to stay
over here in my ihs and hartley fan club
and that's good because i think like
they're
taking members i think there are a lot
of people who like are really like
so have christelle's back and like
aren't in this club with you
and i don't have a real horse in this
race i'm just looking at these pictures
and like
these two are so in love but can i tell
you like i really can't stress enough
how like
i'm in my place not even because of
crochet like it's a very small part of
it no no
i know that has really nothing to do
with that but i'm just saying so many
people are in your place because of
krishel and so
regardless the ends justify the means
you're all ending up in the same place
you know we're all ending up at the same
place i just can't really put my finger
on like what it is that makes me loathe
entirely but there's something there no
i understand it's justin timberlake
vibes
i understand and i just and justin
timberlake has been really quiet
like yeah he got like cancelled and like
now he's just like
gone and then the next documentary is
coming out too about the janet jackson
super bowl and so oh there's more coming
things are only going to get worse for
him
you absolutely love to see it you really
do yeah also
we attempted to go to his bar in
nashville and it was the saddest place
on broadway oh my god i forgot about
that oh my gosh so drunk
okay literally the worst bar on
nashville belongs to justin timberlake
i didn't even know he had a bar and i
kind of love that there's like this
trend
in nashville where you become successful
you get a bar on broadway jason aldean
has one luke bryan
dirks bentley i just saw miranda lambert
has when it looked really cute and like
pleny like it's like it's like the only
one that's not like a dirty dive bar it
looked so cute oh my god we should have
gone
so i just love that and like first of
all justin timberlake
know your place like you're not a
country music singer so get the book out
get the [ __ ] out
and also the place is named 12 30
which is so confusing because margot
literally wrote in our like nashville
chat like
justin timberlake's 12 30.
what does that sentence mean the band
that we liked was going to perform there
i heard him properly where he said we're
going to perform
at 12 30 at 11. you see what i'm saying
yeah and i was in the bathroom and he
made the announcement so margo kind of
regurgitated the announcement in the
chat
and i'm like first of all what does
justin timberlake have to do with this
and two
it's nine o'clock where are we going at
12 30. yeah but his bar is called 12 30
and then we walked in and it was truly a
starbucks like
it was so atrocious and it was like one
block
up on broadway so it's like not even in
a cool place it was just honestly
it was embarrassing like he should be
embarrassed to be associated with that
channel
not to be too harsh or anything yeah no
i agree um
but anyways back to and i just want to
talk about the mtv awards for one second
because i didn't watch them the only
other thing worth mentioning was
addison's outfit yes okay so also it's
worth mentioning that this is not the
vmas
this is the mtv video movie oh okay so
their movie and tv
and then they have their music video
awards so yeah they do have two big
awards shows the vmas are like actually
like a an event in music i think people
like
respect it somewhat um and we always do
attempt to watch yeah
i would watch your bms um the movie and
tv awards are like
best kiss like dummy
you know your face
they do like those dumb [ __ ]
categories like
most screen worthy kiss like the dumbest
[ __ ] like it's
it's actually like the kids choice
awards yes yes it's the teen choice
awards
yeah no those are things those are a
real thing no it's a good choice where
it's like it's so lame so i can't
believe like everyone
celebrities must be just because like
elizabeth olsen was there and like she's
better than that one division swept last
night apparently
oh that's his headline i haven't watched
it yet i know i think that we probably
should
yeah like i literally haven't turned on
my tv in years i finished the bowl type
oh my god um i just i was so upset
like spoiler alert like all this drama
with sutton and the miscarriage and
richard and not wanting to have babies
like
it just not really where i saw the show
going and i'm really upset because like
he left her and like she
like went to harrisburg and just like
[ __ ] that random guy and like
it was just dark like i was really upset
about it yeah
and that's like to me like she's the
only character yeah so it's just like
that's what
i do love getting more developed story
lines from jaclyn like because i
love jaclyn and i don't mind usually
like when a supplemental character like
gets more personal i'm like okay
i'm not interested but i actually love
jaclyn's life because she's like
fabulous and rich and smart and
successful
and like the drama with ian i do enjoy
it so
and oliver love oliver so it's just such
a good show i cannot wait for it to come
back and i'm
so looking forward to just like being a
bull type girly yeah in real time
yeah no it's happening soon which i'm
excited for but
the movie and tv awards um yeah it did
seem like everyone was like showing up
and showing out and it actually felt
like
there was a lot of fanfare and
excitement so i was like happy for
everyone who was excited um and just
addison's outfit like i
truly really enjoy her appreciate her
and i just wasn't totally here for it
but that's fine
the outfit itself yeah personally it
wasn't an outfit i wouldn't wear it
but i think she looked fabulous she's
amazing always she could really wear
anything
that she wants and what's crazy is so
many people have gotten
majorly famous in quarantine yeah this
is their first time stepping out like
even the the outer banks people
chase and madeleine like this was their
first time on a real red carpet they've
been famous for over a year that's
actually an amazing call so and i feel
that way about addison where she became
an a-lister like in
the last year we haven't really seen her
walk major red carpets and like yeah so
this was her first
big like hey look at me moment hey
[Music]
look at me yes brother that's what she
went with and
you know what i think it's like fun and
she looks amazing so and it doesn't
really matter
but it just wasn't my favorite look and
she was there to promote her movie
he saw that she saw that and her and her
co-star like made out on stage like to
pro lina like oh i saw her making out
and i didn't know
if that was her boyfriend no no i think
it was like a stunt
very cool stunt i have a lot of like
kids bop things to watch because high
school musical the musical the series
season two is out
oh so i gotta watch that oh do you wanna
talk about olivia rodrigo
performance yeah um i did watch snl
yesterday and i have to say
it was wholly disappointing especially
after the high of elon not that i
watched this week but i did watch her
performance but like i watched on hulu
and i
i actually skipped through almost every
single sketch it was so not funny
but olivia rodrigo was just like a true
bright spot and
keegan michael key i just feel like he
really wanted to do the most
because that was what his monologue was
about he's like i'm here i want to do it
all i want to sing i want to do sketches
i want to do puppets like
and he did they did a muppet sketch he
did a singing sketch he did multiple
singing sketches with cecily strong it's
like okay we get it you like to sing and
like if that was me on snl
i would be doing the same thing and
people would be saying the same thing
yeah but it's a lot cecily like enough
with the singing
um and i realize how hypocritical that
is of me to say but you know no one's
listening to this podcast anyway
um so it was just like a lot for me and
none of it was funny except
i did audibly like cackle that weekend
update
a multiple of oh okay so literally colin
joe's made
the funniest catch ibm has just
announced that
they have invented the world's smallest
microchip
and colin jose was like not now with the
code and then they had a picture of like
covid vaccine
conspiracy theories it was just really
funny but other than that like it was
honestly like a two out of ten but
olivia rodriguez was
a star star star the outfits
the stage presents the songs the vocals
it was it's we're really watching like a
star being born it's actually amazing
yeah she was great i only watched
driver's license but um
good for you was good i just like really
love deja vu it's honestly becoming like
one of my favorite songs like
ever and i was really looking forward to
hearing her live oh
but we'll see you because the album's
coming out so we're going to be seeing
more olivia yeah
and that's always exciting speaking of
exciting news vanderpump rules as james
kennedy and raquel
levis are engaged see his coachella
themed proposal i didn't know his
coachella
i did and it kind of ruins the good news
but before we dive in
can i let you know a little secret sure
do you know that
today's episode is brought to you by
stamps.com i didn't know you told me
that before the show but don't ruin it
for everyone else tell them are you
still going to the post office
and still paying full price for postage
well thanks to stamps.com you don't have
to anymore
mail and ship anytime anywhere right
from your computer send letters ship
packages and pay
less a lot less with discounted rates
from usps ups and more
stamps.com saves businesses thousands of
hours and tons of money every year
they bring the service of the usps and
ups right to your computer
it's a must-have for any business
whether you're a small office sending
invoices a side hustle etsy shop
shipping orders
or just navigating the hybrid work life
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
and it's a no wonder that over 1 million
businesses choose stamps.com
for their mailing saves you time and
money you get discounts up to 40
off post office rates and up to 66 off
ups shipping rates
so stop wasting your time going to the
post office and go to stamps.com and
said
there's no risk and with our promo code
toast you get a special offer that
includes a four-week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale
there are no long-term commitments or
contracts required
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in toast
that's stamps.com promo code toast
stamps.com
never go to the post office again love
it now that's something to aspire to
yes james and mark keller engaged he
like proposed at the empire
polo fields where they hold coachella
where they held coachella and he
put on rochella i feel like we could
have done better than with the name
no no i actually think it's great
because when i read it i was like
rachella i was like who's rachel's party
that he ruined but i was like no it's
rochella it should have been rockella
well that doesn't make really sense
i think i think he did a good job giving
given the materials um
and they're engaged and they're also
filming vanderpump royals now so i'm
sure they've just been like waiting
all year to get engaged and we're just
like waiting for cameras to go up yeah
and now they're engaged
well i'm really glad about this they
really have grown on me as a couple and
i do think like
they are right for each other yes but in
terms of the aesthetic like
i just think this is like so basic and
lame you mean like the coachel the
rochelle
i thought we were over like naming
things blank chella yeah
no but but for some people it never ends
yeah but just like knowing what i know
about vanderpump rules and coachella
like with the ndas and like
you know james kind of blew up
everyone's spots saying that lala made
everyone sign nda's remember that like
that's where that's what i think of when
i think of james and coachella maybe
he's trying to
shift the association maybe yeah that's
not what i think of but i
i just agree this is like
pretty cheeky yes
yes yes yes yes yes you are right
it is thank you i couldn't find the
right word because it's not even basic
it's just like
uninspired almost yeah but it is
chugalicious definitious
millennials go crazy make those chews go
crazy
stop that is so funny someone needs to
write a parody for delicious chew
delicious
you know who could do it my husband dana
get her on it
i'll get her on the case chugalicious
definition make the boys go loco
no make the choke so loco yeah yeah it's
chewy like it's just kind of like a lame
thing but i'm really happy for them as a
couple
yeah and they're it seems like they're
you know bringing out all the stops for
vanderpump rules and it's it's gonna
it's gonna be dicey
yeah i have like a pit about it like i
have no faith
in the future of vanderpump rules like
see what you want about the stasis and
the jaxes and the christians like
that's tv like they were unreal at their
jobs at being
true sociopaths like and you really
can't
replicate that no and they tried and now
it's like we're wiping clean
like charlie and danica the suspended
manager like
they're not coming back so it's just so
messy oh okay i think i saw her i saw a
group photo i saw ariana sheena lala
katie charlie raquel like it's just like
it's uninspired and i'm and i'm very
nervous
yeah i'm nervous too so but i've been
meaning for things to take off my
content plate
and so if it sucks like that will be
great for me easy
and easy goodbye yeah because like we're
kind of in like a
a transitional phase right now shots of
sunset premiered last night and my dvr
was not working i wanted to you know
someone will dvr
yes i do yes thank you for like
i feel sick and sorry i just i do like
it's always [ __ ] like [ __ ] with no
like i came to your house to watch
something you're like oh no we have to
watch in the bedroom it only recorded in
here like no that's not living no no
okay that wasn't like a problem i
recorded it in the bedroom i wanted to
watch a view like
no but like when you record something it
should record to your devices without
you having to like set up
special stuff can i just tell you like i
have spectrum time warner cable
that's the cheaper alternative like you
can only you can press record on things
in the living room and it records on all
the other tvs
but like i paid extra to have special
dvrs in every room because what i need
in the living room is not what i need in
the bedroom no but like also clearly
like you're not getting a lot of storage
because then i also watched you like
immediately delete the thing
but that's my that's my ocd okay i
delete everything
my youtube tv library has everything of
all time it's actually amazing i can log
into my account anywhere i go
and i could watch anything i could do
that if i wanted to but i have like i
have ocd
and i actually have childhood trauma
because like when we used to
when we were growing up the dvr was in
the living room and everyone recorded
their own things but like
it adds up and it can only store so much
and like
literally what it was became it was like
a household chore like to be the one to
clean out the dvr when it was at 99
and like that's trump traumatic yeah i
agree but i'm just saying like you
knock on youtube tv a lot there's no
storage thing
at youtube we just rewind i don't really
think that i do that no you do
i'm sure we could roll tapes no i
actually don't think i make fun of you
for having youtube
tv ever i just think maybe i you know
marvel
often at the fact that you don't have
cable like you're such a chew
that's kind of cute you know i'm saying
you're chuggy but that's a very
anti-choogy behavior
yeah i just don't also just don't think
i'm like that chewy i evaluated myself
this weekend and the two levels were low
um i don't agree you think i'm chewy a
little yeah
in which ways just like in your age and
like your
job being a podcaster
yeah podcasting is definitely too gay no
i don't think so
i do no choose to look like a count
executive
no like yes but gen z is like don't
listen to podcasts
no i don't think they're talking i
really don't think they're talking about
me
i hope not i'm sure there's a different
word for me but
i don't think it's cheeky but let me
know maybe i'm just
i can't see myself you know yeah no i
think maybe you're right maybe
you know um but back to racquel and
james happy for them
fifth and final story are you ready for
it it's the final
story
bill gates stepped down for microsoft
board after investigation of an affair
with an employee you guys
this bill gates divorce is blowing
everything wide open his
dirty laundry is being aired for the
world shit-stained underwear
no and it's [ __ ] dirty nasty too
dirty
stacked up yeah dirty if you ain't dirty
you ain't here to party
ladies move gentlemen move everybody
bring this this is a little cheeky of us
bring me along no way bring me alone
bill gates is laundry and song even go
how does the chorus i want to get a
little bit
yeah so anyways bill gates has it on
repeat after his
dirty laundry was has it coming to light
now he was investigated for a past
affair with an employee after the
staffer brought it to light in 2019
leading to the founder stepping down
from the microsoft board last year
according to her new report
gates however claims the investigation
was not the reason for his stepping down
sure yeah
you know like you were set why that why
the hell else would you step down at the
literally
on the same week of your company yeah
like literally the same day that there
was a complaint lodged against you been
there for 30 years we're going to step
down
the same day has nothing to do no also
there's a lot of weird [ __ ] coming out
about him like he had a girlfriend who
like he had
bought her a house like on the beach and
like he was allowed to go on vacation
with her once a year like that was an
agreement in their marriage yeah and
there's also um
rumor swirling that he consulted um
convicted sex offender jeffrey epstein
for advice on how to end his marriage
the gates spokesperson said that was
false but i don't know why they would
say it was true
100 and oh my god this is like
it's just so crazy because i actually
feel like
their divorce probably on both of their
accounts but mostly on his like
was intentionally delayed because
divorces just get messy and like [ __ ]
like this comes out
and i think bill gates was probably
wondering like would i rather be stuck
in this loveless marriage or have my
shitstain
laundry hung out to dry yeah and he
chose the ladder it's really a jeff's
choice
because jeff bezos went through
something similar yeah
when he was like should i stay in my
loveless marriage or should i risk it
all
for lord and he risked it all and i
think bill like looked at him and was
like
okay like that was pretty embarrassing
but like look what he's fine he seems
like a man in love
yeah so i think bill really just made
the best of his jeff's choice
i'm really struggling not to say
something i mean about who it's just so
funny like what money does to a man
you know like half of these
whatever i'm not going to say it okay
okay i think it's for the best
okay sure the wall street journal
reports that gates was being
investigated by an outside law firm
hired by microsoft board members after
one of the company's engineers claim she
had once had a years-long
sexual relationship with gates dating
back to the year 2000.
did she say it was a consensual
relationship um yeah
well she didn't it doesn't say
consensual or non-consensual but it was
years long
starting in 2000 okay so it's like 20
years how old is she
unclear the board ultimately decided
gates should step down the outlet said
and gates formally stepped down from the
microsoft and berkshire hathaway boards
in march 2020.
at the time he said the decision was he
so he could dedicate more time to
philanthropic priorities
oh don't throw your charities under the
bench
so we're going to come into this global
health and development education
and my increasing engagement in tackling
climate change
it's weird like literally in march 2020
he turned his priority to global health
hmm
that's kind of weird giving the
conspiracy theorists like a run for
their money 100
no i mean ah
oh bail oh bill you know what he's just
like
i just like can't describe what i'm
feeling like okay
do you want to try i'm just going to try
and work through it privately or
publicly
i think it's best if i do it privately
because
i don't want to say something but like
what i'm thinking is like bill gates
is a loser
like i just like i just
i need to work through my my feelings
because i've never really given much
time or thought to bill gates
his career his marriage or his personal
life but i'm just kind of feeling like
there's a big losery stench coming from
it
no i agree and i have to be honest like
i'm having deja vu from jeff bezos
text messages and just like you like
these are the people in
like literally who run the world and
like they're big families
yeah but yes of course it's like you
really get to know like what they're
i think it's maybe just like the way
that bill gates looks like i just can't
see him like having sex with anyone he's
like
the definition of a nerd do you know
what i mean like with his glasses from
the 19 they're bifocals like they're
literally from the 70s like
he just gives me like major nerdy ass
vibes
and i'm like this is the man who like
you know can't
keep the women off him you know i'll
tell you about jeff misos
no jeff bezos okay he's not like the
most handsome man
but there's a cuteness to it like a
little q-tip cue ball moment
i would argue the opposite like billy
would you rather [ __ ]
bill gates or jeff bezos
don't make me do this but it's so easy
yeah of course ben said bezos he's 10
months then you want to [ __ ] basis
ben said he would [ __ ] bezos for 190
billion also ben's in the studio today
oh ben said he would do it for less he
would do it for a billion i would let
you do it for the billion but i get half
i get half yeah yeah of course that's
fine
you do what you got to do you
if you don't believe in yourself who
will yeah no definitely jeff bezos is
not like i said like a stunner but he's
cute he's cute
wow okay imagine if he was a stunner it
would actually be unfair
like genetically like it's just not fair
okay i feel that
that's kind of like i thought in my
opinion of all like the mega rich
you know the richest people in america
like elon musk is like the cutest one
just from a physical standpoint like
he's in my opinion
the most conventionally handsome and
that's it's like not fair because he's
obviously like a genius too like you
don't really get all the decks
the cards in your deck yeah no but i
think like elon
is so handsome like because of
everything else he has going on for him
but when i think of like all these like
tech people i think the one who's
actually handsome is like evan spiegel
from snapchat and then so hot and that's
why he married miranda
so hot and they're just like happy with
what they have like snapchat's not the
biggest or
no but they they're still billionaires
they have happiness yeah that's so true
you know oh my god he like really
doesn't let him get him down like all
these other guys with all their
complexes like they would not stop until
snapchat
was like was the biggest that's like
mark zuckerberg the same way right but i
think he has a complex
by the way you are 100 right like evan
spiegel is like
it now that i think about like the only
of all the big like tech
guys like i think he's like the only one
who i would consider
conventionally handsome conventionally
handsome and like seems happy just with
what he's got
yeah like i bet if that were me like i
would wake up every morning and be like
damn i should have taken that three
million dollars from facebook
but he doesn't see it that way yeah no i
think it's like it
it's nice i think he's acknowledges the
space that he's in and he says his
blessings and he's married to victoria's
secret supermodel and that probably
wouldn't have happened if he didn't
create snapchat right happy for him
okay well that is our analysis on all
the richest men in the world and whether
or not they're cute let us know if you
want a patreon episode on that
there's so much more to go like there
are many others too yeah
there's a lot there and that and then
it's like we're in the billionaire space
right now
but we could operate in like hundreds of
millions of space too that really opens
it up
also we recently learned kanye west is a
billionaire a billionaire and i would
say he's
very handsome very very handsome so
there's just maybe we'll put together
like a slideshow or something
yeah and pros and cons pros and cons but
like honestly i really hope that bill
gates gets like a post-marriage glow up
and he takes the bifocals off and like i
don't know gets a buzz cut or something
like
he needs he wears the same like he
he has looked the same since he first
popped on the scene like he's the same
man
yeah he just needs to refresh okay
yeah bezos got like a new vibe like when
he
did he yeah he's buying a 500 million
dollar yacht but like that's
but but that's not what you're saying
that nobody just like
you know he's he's got swagger he's
he's changing it up and i think i think
bill saw this
and wanted it for himself i want that do
you think they all talk like they've
group chat like bill bezos elon musk
no who else is in that list um
i'm just gonna google richie's men in
america yeah
richest man in the world in the world
i think so okay bezos is number one
bill gates warren buffett mark
zuckerberg
i feel like there's definitely a chat
with mark zuckerberg bill gates and jeff
bezos just like
how to control the world oh larry page
from google i don't know a lot of these
people elon musk is there oh michael
bloomberg i always forget he's like so
rich
remember when he paid all those meme
accounts to post about him running for
president that was when
honestly that was like a low for
humanity
that really was oh mackenzie bezos scott
is on
wow that's crazy and soon melinda
soon no even though they like pledged
all their money away i don't get how
that works
how are you on the list if you pledged
all your money away you're still on the
list
who's bernard arnold and family lvmh
oh they oh this is such a great little
that's a fun one it tells you everything
okay this is a great like fabulous
little list okay so
jeff bezos amazon bernard lvmh elon musk
tesla bill gates microsoft mark
zuckerberg facebook warren buffett
berkshire hathaway which is what you
were just saying i guess they own
microsoft no
bill gates sat on the board of berkshire
halfway got it halfway
would you say half away did i see that
you're gonna need halfway
sorry larry ellison does software
larry page that's like um oracle
probably larry page does google sergey
brin
also at google ah amancio ortega
zara guess what i think it is because of
your hall
100 guess what his net worth is uh oh
we're in the high billions
um 75 billion very close 88.
wow francois bettencourt myers and
family which is l'oreal
mukesh ambani his portfolio is diverse
diversified that's what it says
steve balmer microsoft carlos slim helu
and family of telecom alice walton
that oh no she's the second woman on the
list um alice walton walmart
wait do they call it walmart because
their last name is walton
for sure yeah wow you learned something
new every day
oh all the other waltons are on the list
too in 17 and 18. jim walton and rob
walton of walmart i wonder how alice got
to the top good for alice
yeah i don't must be the matriarch
michael bloomberg of course mackenzie
scott hers says
amazon oh okay phil knight and family
nike
okay michael dell of dell computers
charles
[ __ ] coach the koch brothers you know
of coach industries koch coke coke are
you sure yeah
okay i don't know a bunch of these these
um quicken loans
tick tock nutella oh my god the man who
meant to nutella is on
it's 36 on the list ben close your ears
giovanni ferreiro
chanel is on here watch out for giovanni
casinos it's so interesting that they
put their industry like
is there any podcasters on here
that's very upsetting lots of steel oh
how interesting the quinn yingling and
family
are 30.5 billionaires from
pig breeding that's something i never
thought i would hear in my life you
learned something new every day
eyeglasses package it's a lot of like
things you would assume estee lauder
chemicals hedge funds real estate
smartphones oil
bmw medical devices i just want to see
if there's anything like crazy on here
like
mining oh interesting welder's gotta
weld welder's gonna well alcohol
e-commerce
cheese emanuel besnia
has 19 billion dollars and he makes
cheese
nice i love that for him keto season
keto season okay i could literally look
at this list all day this is like a
who's who of you know who we gotta get
in with
nice okay mom
that's up that's that on that and that's
our show is it
yeah i mean those were the fast five
stories i feel as though you needed to
know them
um this week we've got great we're here
all week so
don't worry about that don't even think
about worrying about it yeah we've got
tv recaps
revving up again coming at you yes
jersey is
ending beverly hills starts next week
like there's just
we're in a transitional time yeah we
really are so
stay tuned for all of it thank you so
much for listening to the morning toast
millennium morning show where we go
where we post videos where we deliver
the fastback stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so
spotify institute public radio my heart
rated chessbox all the places regulars
in a podcast
find out some morning shows leave a five
star view about how beautiful stunning
and smart we are oh my god that's
beautiful
thank you everyone have a great day
we'll see you tomorrow goodbye